foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
people from Big conservative companies
only 24 Live reads I didn't agree to
that
[Applause]
only only 24 Live reads
[Music]
thank you
all know me
y'all know I earn a living
I'll catch this broad for you but it
ain't gonna be easy
it's a bad
I like going down to social media and
chasing down Jack dorsey's or Zuckerberg
is Mohan
he'll swallow your channels whole
restrictions
denominations and down you go
no we gotta do it quick
gotta bring back all your rightful
subscribers and convert them to mug
clubbers on a paying basis
but it's not going to be pleasant
all right well you might Channel a whole
lot more than three thousand bucks chief
I'll find her for three
but I'll bring my half asian lawyer and
Sewer for ten
now you got to make up your minds you
want to keep your channels alive and any
up
you want to play it cheap you'll be
listening to non-stop libraries and
Rhino talking points the whole winter I
don't want no GoFundMe I don't want no
patreons I have too many damn why they
conservatives on this platform
ten thousand dollars for me and my half
asian lawyer Bill Richmond by ourselves
for that you get the head
a snazz
the whole damn thing
thank you very much Rumble Quint um
we will take it under advisements
Mr Mayor
chief
ladies and Z's
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh that is very nice it's very nice it's
not too hot not too hot which yes I
forgot I scalded my mouth uh the first
few days this week hey today is a
special uh we haven't done one of these
in a while a special live check live
fact check stream live fact hold on a
second
live fact check stream I got the red
tide so bear with me uh we have the tick
tock man
um also a Coco melon standing uh Mr Chu
what's his name
don't say it like that bless you no I
just did I said it quickly show Chu
talking before is it a house committee
yes house committee uh today about Tick
Tock uh and of course you know we've
been banned from Tick Tock for a very
long time proudly so and we think that
Tick Tock should be banned from the
United States because it's um spyware uh
a biggest defender of tick tock
remaining of course is one Eric swalwell
so we'll get to that
so we'll be doing that live so please do
uh you know tune in here we're going to
go to it as it continues right now it's
taking place but before that we have
some other stories to get to gonna be
talking about Canada they have a big
tourism uh issue that's going on right
now and it's a you know a fascist
hellhole uh Hillary Clinton is teaching
a new class at Columbia ah yes which is
always funny
and uh I don't think we're gonna be
talking about the LA yeah mainly Tick
Tock is the stream uh today but you know
him you love him in chair too and
tomorrow by the way tomorrow is the
first time where you get to watch a
Friday show Gerald Morgan Junior how are
you I am doing well sir how are you I'm
doing well explain to people where they
can tune in tomorrow right to watch the
Friday show which is we're going to do
on mug club right so we might have the
first like 15 minutes available if you
happen to be watching on some stupid
platform called YouTube but if you're
also watching on Rumble you can watch
the first 15 but go over to mug Club
this is going to be one of those first
things you have some behind the scenes
footage that we've shot and then also
Brian Callan and I did our first episode
of Gerald apologizes apologetics yes and
so that's going to be a lot of fun and
by the way that's not what it means no
it's not no I don't know who came so you
do need to apologize for your mere
presence here in the studio and it is
still free it's all free this month
lateral credit.com you don't need to
enter in your credit card info any of
that you just sign up create an account
and then afterwards if you want to stick
around you can stick around to my
question to you as we go into this live
fact check there you go got it nice see
red tide ain't got nothing on me well
not yet uh stream I don't know what I
was going to say now
a lot of credit.com mug Club I will be
getting into this and of course uh he is
here in third chair he's going to be in
Portland at Helium Comedy Club April
20th through the 22nd I believe and a
lot of you don't know a man who loves
his country uh uh kind of I don't want
to say out of the closet but kind of
Ryan Callan how are you sir I'm I'm just
a man just a man happy to be here well
yeah we didn't know
these uh these cans bring out my nose or
what guys huh come on you got a nice
Roman nose it's called an aqualine nose
is that what it's called that's what
it's called I don't believe that's what
it is yes of course let's do like the
Romans do and kidnap Seven Brides so
they can't scream and their parents
can't say them over the winter and we'll
force them to marry us look there it is
me too wasn't wrong about everything uh
do I know he's a little bit smaller than
Alex Jones do we need to bring his
microphone closer to him at all or are
we good there Yakuza I think he sounds
fine I'll keep it okay another
announcement apologize for being so
shredded Nick de Paulo hey let's not
speak ill of these yes
smells like Chemtrails here you should
have heard our conversation with Alex
Jones off air so much fun oh my gosh
sometimes it's really hard for me to get
these things done uh you know oh Lord I
gotta get out of Austin I started
smoking a little bit but I don't really
smoke and no I don't know maybe go to
rehab just for smoking
you know which county has a conservative
judge I'm just like Alex go home
his theories are amazing I uh I did
drink some water though some tap water
and I ended up having
sex with a guy yeah
I found a frog in the water so I think
that's that's an excuse and it's only
gay if you're smiling right he doesn't
have that as a theory yeah it's just
something you did it's a proven science
just trying to tell you what Alex Jones
said was okay yes you can have sex with
a guy as long as you drink the right or
the wrong water yeah the carbon filter
you can get that at Infowars uh
infowarshop.com sure if you want to be
as long as you put in some oil oregano
and colloidal silver okay you will not
become a demonic gay frog all right Nick
depala by the way his show is coming to
my club April 10th 5 p.m many of you
were asking for the announcement when
like so he's coming April 10th you'll be
getting that show four times a week yeah
and we'll be making the announcements
regarding Mr guns and gear uh the comedy
specials that we have not only with
Callan not only with Brewer but also
other weekly and daily shows by the way
if you're somebody who is following Nick
DePaul right now if you're on his
patreon make sure we're gonna have a
page for him so you can sign up under
his portal we'll have that ready to go
we'll make sure that we to get that out
too and next team we'll get that out
this is eight minutes of announcements
let's move on all right Sunday morning
before we get to everything else there
was a potential mass shooting I don't
know if you heard about this good guy
with a gun quick fact by the way when
people argue with you about how many if
it saves one life okay fine so you're
talking about tens of thousands always
under 30 000 when you talk about
homicides right if you include suicides
gun deaths in this country on the high
end 40 something thousand on the low end
30 something thousand when you're
talking about homicides it's about
fifteen thousand anywhere to twenty
something thousand on a really really
busy year over two million defensive
uses of firearms every single year it's
done if it saves one life okay well we
save give or take two million so this is
another example of uh not exactly but
kind of it's more entertaining Sunday
morning a potential Mass shooter would
be Mass shooter I guess I should say
would be was stopped uh by a bouncer
outside of um the strip a strip club in
Tampa let's watch
so here we go you can just play some
music here this is uh well no that's the
that's the first guy who goes in I guess
Vader mankind it's going in with a gun
to a strip club now look at this guy
takes his gun wow stops him yep boom
takes it out
get the gun shoot Vader doesn't know
what to do he still has the gun no it's
on the ground
he doesn't have the gun I'm going to say
he should have shoot he should shoot him
right now I agree with you right with
that guy's pants are down but he pistol
whips him okay which is a pimp move
yep piss the whip with your pants down
this is what you get for dropping out of
law school yep exactly that man must
really hate strippers I'll tell you what
I had no idea that Mick Foley was that
anti-strip you see the guy in the gray
sweater run out and he literally takes
time to roll up his sleeves
[Laughter]
the guy who understands being present
DJ runs out he's like huh
no way I'm gonna look back on this
moment
yeah
hold on hold him still for a second
gentlemen I don't want to get any gems
in my hands I don't have to do the
Timothy Olyphant Hitman yes I don't want
to get crazy juice on my fingers here's
the funny part I shouldn't say funny
part here's the even better part uh the
hero there was actually also a 55 year
old x-pro wrestler
Manuel Manny Resto who was once called
the Puerto Rican Punisher that's the guy
you beat up and he thought watch the
interview with this guy I didn't need a
mask this man's a hero yep I was a
professional wrestler MMA guy I know a
lot of big guys I've worked security for
30 years I know a lot of bouncers I
thought it was one of my friends playing
a trick on me so I was like so I was
kind of smiling while it was approaching
he was approaching he was he approached
slowed measured steps
and he didn't say a word and I was
waiting for the punch line
well you delivered it then all of a
sudden he came right up to me and he was
a very big man very big I was like okay
then he walked beside me I guess he
thought I didn't work there or I wasn't
a threat or whatever so he was right
beside me I was to the left he he was to
the right I saw him raise his hand and
he had
a gun
we don't have so much care if you were
to his left and right like we know our
left and right at this point we just
want to know that you put him in a
shallow grave and yeah good for you
that's right well yeah absolutely what
kind of friends does this guy have by
the way he's like yeah I thought it was
just one of my buddies yeah oh yeah the
old the old bring a loaded firearm into
a strip club trick yeah it took a long
time to describe that that's that's slow
processing he's got a gun a flashlight
he's very big yes is this a mass
shooting or is just is this just the old
bring a semi-automatic handgun right
he's got the into the strip club a bit
he's got he's got darkness and ta and
kill tattooed to his uh to his arms yeah
exactly I don't want to look are those
henna tattoos if they're a henna tattoos
it's safe I thought it might be some
kind of a fraternity hazing until I
realized that uh he had soulless eyes
and that's when I decided I needed to do
something so I promptly beat the hell
out of it looks like brown warm cheese
yes I'm just saying guys not the fat
shame but seriously and by the way
speaking of of brown and Puerto Rican uh
our agent William is going to be on the
show later today uh because he has
thoughts on Puerto Ricans yeah uh so and
if you see this take place during the
show if you're watching on YouTube head
on over to rumble because on YouTube you
may see and hear this at some point in
the program
[Music]
yeah there you go all right let's get
the tricaster a little bit there you go
that means that it's not available on
YouTube but if you go over to rumble you
can see exactly what we're talking about
at that moment in time because uh we're
not going to self-center say whatever
you want Brian don't worry about it
thank you buddy so let's move on here
before we get to The Tick Tock live
stream and fact checking it which is
going to be uh I'm sure there's a lot to
get into uh Canada my home it's a silly
place it's a stupid place
uh they're getting in hot water right
now and uh we'll we'll then tell you why
this matters to you because I know
you're thinking does this matter it's a
slow news day but stay with us
Regina Saskatchewan is facing criticism
over a new tourism campaign uh and then
we got the new clip right the extended
clip yeah so uh see if you can guess why
[Applause]
oh sorry that was wrong oh okay I was
confused let's bring in the Regina
Saskatchewan tourism clip see if you can
guess why it's a problem terrible
that's what I think terrible publicity
that's not exactly a ringing endorsement
and not I think what you want to hear if
you've just launched a new campaign to
promote tourism in Regina
last week tourism Regina rebranded
itself as experienced Regina through a
rendition of the Spiral video but its
attempt at a new name was quickly
forgotten when it launched using slogans
like show us your Regina and the city
that rhymes with fun
[Laughter]
this is why you don't trust experts
because that went through an entire
panel people sat down yeah they they
brainstormed they workshopped and then
someone said
how about show us your Regina I'm good
are we good yeah meeting adjourned yep
no one had the forethought to say
wait
well also
yeah the fact that Regina is in
French yes right right so that's the
other problem they have a lot of
different I mean I've been in that town
have you yeah it's it's a warm tight
yeah yeah it is it's a tightness it
rains a lot yeah but uh I don't know why
it seems like they're always it's I get
the sense they're always like cooking
like steaming mussels that's it
certainly smells that way here's the
thing if you're going in south on the
map there's the town of anus Yes again
yes there's you know Latin for of course
butthole yeah so Latin yes yeah these
are the romance languages which is
obviously very fitting right and don't
forget of course their sister city in
Europe uh frenulum
Dolores this is this is not bad you're
being immature now that now you're come
in Regina
just say like Regina is a good City you
know I mean like hey I like regen well
no it's almost like it's impossible to
get around Regina I like Regina what
happens here stays I heart Regina I got
Regina
it's hard to miss Regina it's Regina I
was in Regina and all I got was a stupid
uh clap I don't know like there's no
good I guess it's really
antibiotics that don't work yes exactly
and it was worth it
worth it so here's the issue it's silly
it should be fun but talitha McCloskey
from the women's group raise her and I
know what you're thinking hey I must
hate that group even though I don't know
what it is yeah correct
they were critical of the campaign and
said the objectification of vaginas is
not okay generally I would agree with
you but in this case you need to leave
right because she doesn't know how to
spell vagina right exactly and she also
understands this is a city right this is
a city it's the city of Regina Regina
yeah it's a city which neighbor close to
close yeah well you know what I also
hate though too is the city the city
keeps going through problems because it
wasn't Regina it was it was a different
city before and they have to dilate it
for two hours every day with a medical
device
I have to look that up fact check please
fact check now just watch I am Jazz
it'll be all you need to know and this
is the thing it's this is in related
news of someone else who you can't stand
stay with me for a second here Gwyneth
Paltrow I know you threw up in your
mouth a little bit she just appeared in
court this week in more proof that
elitists don't believe the rules apply
uh to them because she skied into
somebody causing irreparable harm
Gwyneth Paltrow rushes into court
wearing dark sunglasses and a long coat
with security by her side are you
confident are you gonna win this case
moments later the Oscar winner turned
Wellness Guru walked into the courtroom
in a cream turtleneck sweater and brown
pants Paltrow is facing Terry Sanderson
a 76 year old retired optometrist who
claims she plowed into him on a ski
slope leaving him with four broken ribs
and permanent brain damage most happens
in Regina is you plow oh and then
Paltrow's defense her attorney said that
actually
um the client his client Gwyneth Paltrow
is innocent it was actually Sanderson
that crashed into her and here here's
the thing that may be true considering
that there Destiny motive he he has a
bill of receipt or at least it was
discovered yeah that uh he received the
wrong um scented candle from Gwyneth
Paltrow's Candle Company and so he could
be upset okay wow was he wearing the
candle he wasn't wearing the candle but
it's like it's like uh smelling salts I
see oh he was in the Chalet he smelled
it I gotta kill this because you can
wear she has a a jade egg which
apparently is good for your Yoni
it's good for Saskatchewan no but her
Regina you can wear it in your Regina
yes exactly I think and you can light it
on fire right you know what that's what
what's the name of it Jade doesn't carry
smells the group is what is it raise her
that's what you should be upset about
not hey come to Regina or Regina's or
fun or show us your Regina you should be
mad about if you're saying objectifying
women's nether regions how about
lighting at a blaze I'm with you
wouldn't that that's where I draw the
line yeah lighting lighting your vagina
Ablaze yeah that's sending the wrong
message I agree with you with Gwyneth
Paltrow she's a very she's 800 calories
a day roughly apparently really very
thin woman it's like getting hit
buy a wooden chair you know what I mean
yeah yeah and that can cause all kinds
of problems I understand it seems like
she's starving her soul because she's
all worse she's all points she's the
worst human being alive don't worry the
reporters are on it they're describing
her wardrobe as she walks in that's like
the most is that she's got a cream
sweater and a brown skirt Gwyneth
Paltrow wearing a cream sweater brown
skirt and having soulless lifeless eyes
like a doll's eyes showed up and claimed
she was the victim this is the lady who
in fact does sell candles scented like
her poonanny so you know what your guess
is as good as ours but we're gonna phone
in guilty right and she's covered in
Coop yes yeah is goop the name of her
company well that's uh that's the name
of this ski hill in Regina
oh no speaking of antibiotics it itches
and burns yeah it's just like those
firefighters who drop the water on the
forest Burns they just drop that's what
you do the clap antibiotics all you need
is to eat a lot of garlic apparently yes
and love and read your Bible All You
Need Is Love so let's go to this
speaking of love because we need to fill
up with love because now we're about to
get to something that we hate and I know
it's wrong to hate let me know do you
ever feel that in you like hate when you
there's certain people who bring it out
of me uh Hillary Clinton's one of them
yes so and by the way this is a live
show Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern that's the bet well actually
Monday through Friday now 10 a.m Eastern
just go to loudoscredit.com don't do the
social media passive scrolling like look
tune in watch check the references we
make available and then move on with
your day which we'll be talking about
with Tick Tock it's harming children's
brains There's an actual yeah uh there's
an entire organization there's actually
there are many different scientific
groups now there are meta-analysis that
have been conducted and social media
particularly Tick Tock uh these devices
and of course the platforms on these
devices that encourage five second views
five second views and passive
consumption of content not only harms
your brain this may be the first
generation that has a lower IQ than the
previous generation so we'll get into
that in a second and see what Mr Chu
says before the house committee my guess
is he lies uh but speaking of educated
guesses here Hillary Clinton she's now
teaching a class uh at Columbia and they
announced it
with this
uh I'm trying to think of how to
describe it have you ever like have you
ever had like palpable lack of
self-awareness that's this video oh my
God what is it it's Hillary Clinton
she's running what wait is she teaching
at Columbia University or in Colombia
movie
here I am
you're hurry you're running again
well I sure am I just got here early for
the new class we're teaching together on
foreign policy decision making classes
don't start until
septembered
situations you've always got to be
prepared prepared I think you're more
prepared than anyone to teach this
course now what are we going to call it
inside the Situation Room you mean
you're fair and womb and I'll cover the
theory of political decision making and
strategy and I'll cover what it was
actually like in the room during the bin
Laden raid the Iran sanctions the Gaza
ceasefire she wasn't there okay but are
you ready for whatever questions the
students throw at you bring it on
if you'll excuse me Karen I've gotta run
yeah run is a very generous term I gotta
run I got the runs
it's a complete waddle it's a side to
side shift
it's like she's on strings yes exactly
holding those those feet I got these
strings to hold all you have to do is
apparently she teaches you what it's
like to be a she wants to get more women
in foreign policy so you just have to
get into Colombia and
spend four hundred thousand dollars on
an education and in four years you can
encourage and support the women of
Afghanistan and Benghazi yes exactly and
of course not have sex with Bill Clinton
be the only person in the sorority who
doesn't have sex with him and in the
White House yes and in the white house
the entire West Wing really you could
cover the entire State and by the way
Columbia University the president had
this to say about Hillary given her
extraordinary talents and capacities
together with her singular life
experiences Hillary Clinton is unique
and most importantly exceptional in what
she can bring to the University's
missions of research and teaching so
look here's the real issue that that
bothers me here we always talk about
girls needing strong role models and
there are some very strong Role Models
out there by the way
um but when you say Hillary Clinton is a
good role model for young women you're
encouraging them to be vapid Gold
Digging yes but but with a law
degree okay can I just say that
respectfully yes yes with a law degree
and you know by the way the mug Club is
free letterscar.com here are a few let
me prove to you all month why Hillary
Clinton I know you're singing that's
conjecture no no Hillary is completely
unqualified yeah uh for any of her jobs
ever uh she was the architect by the way
in case you don't know this uh and
removing uh Gaddafi from power and uh
here she is by the way celebrating and
just so you know I get that a lot of
people Gaddafi bad guy right yeah yeah
but she did throw the kind like toss
them and missed a civil war it didn't
have a plan after so just like get rid
of that guy but we don't know what the
hell and the why matters because the
only reason she wanted to kill Gaddafi
was because she thought it was a photo
negative of Jeff Ross so here she is
celebrating
yes we came we saw he died
anything to do with your visit no I'm
sure it did
but then there were open air slave
markets in Libya I don't know if you
guys know that yeah oh yeah I just want
to speak for the latter with Crowder no
we're anti-slavery yes generally
speaking unless it's slavery sexual
involuntary yeah right exactly everyone
yeah exactly was okay no it was not
matters no I mean it's indentured
servitude ah yes yeah yeah yeah like in
Dubai where you know all the wealthy go
to play but don't worry nine years of
Civil War it's okay yeah no just nine
years so when you're telling young women
she's qualified to teach again here's my
question here's a genuine question
comment below let's say you are not a
conservative you are not okay
what are Hillary's greatest
qualifications what has she actually
accomplished aside from not sleeping
with Bill Clinton and I mean that what
has she done where she has been because
she's very successful when it comes to
not banging Bill Clinton she's tops no
one's higher on the totem pole or not on
the totem pole like Hillary Clinton
outside of that I am at a loss I want
you to tell me let me give you another
reason again I don't think young girls
should be looking up to Hillary Clinton
uh here's reason number two Hillary
Clinton uh would be Benghazi obviously
right she obstructed an order from the
commander-in-chief delayed the rescue
mission people are saying oh you're
playing politics you have the Sam Harris
of the world like you're just playing
politics in retrospection no no no lives
could have been saved just to be clear
as to the severity of Benghazi and she
opted to not so here's a direct quote
from uh the hill the delay in launching
a rescue mission was not due to the
quote tyranny of time and distance
rather it was a total failure of
secretary of state that was Hillary
Clinton most you probably didn't know to
lead wow even after receiving the news
and of course that resulted in the death
yet Chris Stevens you know information
officer Sean Smith special operators um
it was a den uh Glenn Doherty and um uh
was it Tyron Woods yeah yeah I'm not
good with names but they're okay they're
not to be a lot of people died because
of Hillary Clinton and that's kind of a
demerit when you're talking about being
Secretary of State that's right well
absolutely one of the things too you
remember if you ever watched the movie
13 hours the guys at the end that show
up and actually help people they're not
the people that we helped get free from
Gaddafi they were Gaddafi loyalists
right so the people that we helped were
like yeah we got better things to do
it's a Friday night we're partying thank
God I never saw the problem is I was
trying to watch uh 13 hours and
accidentally rented 13 Ghosts Ah that's
I don't recommend it yeah no and then I
thought that I was watching uh ghosts
from Mars or that film was I never saw
it and then I realized I was watching 13
Ghosts so of those three films I had
definitively the worst one yeah but I
had paid for it right the sequel yeah 14
ghosts yes exactly one more it's worse
this just in though just like the sequel
to The Event Horizon I don't know if you
ever saw event Sunset no I did not see
it event Sunset yeah but I lived it now
listen uh this just in uh Hillary
Clinton's class off also offers sort of
an offshoot where you learn how to
delete
she is very good and here's the thing
too just you know there's a lot of
conjecture people saying well okay she
deleted emails and I get it people play
political
[Music]
foreign
here's something else again think about
this raise her is that what it was raise
her protect her raise her by the way
this is also a thing too everything is
sexist Hellraiser I know you know now is
a woman it's like Hellraiser is a
demonic androgynous the whole point is
that it doesn't have they're like you
know what we feel that women are
underrepresented in torturous demonic
Soul fiends so we need a woman
Hellraiser we can be demonic and
too yeah exactly right it changed from
such sights to show you too what do you
think of this right what did you tell
your friend because that's not what I
heard look at her dress yeah look at her
dress is that what you want do you want
me to be like that no answer
it's fine I'm fine yes it's fine I'm
fine
by the way here's the number one reason
while we're talking about the it's the
hypocrisy and by the way it's not that
people are hypocrites I've talked about
this like when covet happened and Nancy
Pelosi went and she went the uh the the
particle Vortex to get her hair blown
out it's not the hip-hop everyone is a
hypocrite every person in this room is a
hypocrite certainly if you have a set of
beliefs if you're a Christian I've
talked about this of course you are a
hypocrite that's not an argument the
issue is not the hypocrisy it's that
they don't believe it you can believe
something for example you can believe
that drinking too much is bad and being
alcoholic you can believe genuinely that
pornography is bad and as a man still go
oh there's another naked lady and you're
tempted by it the issue is they don't
believe in the idea of patriarchy and
sexism and that women are oppressed or
the idea that asking questions or maybe
perhaps being skeptical of the rape
statistics that they try and give you uh
are are they are our byproduct of
patriarchal society they don't believe
it because they don't apply it
consistently that's the problem don't
say hypocrisy look at their action and
say hold on a second do they believe it
because they accuse the right of
constantly being victim blamers is there
any greater victim blamer throughout
history than Hillary Clinton she called
Jennifer Flowers trailer trash she of
course she was out there just tarring
and Feathering Monica Lewinsky who by
the way was in love with her husband
which makes one of them the point is
that was an abusive Authority
and people always say oh oh so he slept
with a few people no Bill Clinton didn't
just sleep Bill Clinton would he
sexually he tried he had sex with women
who weren't even willing that's the
issue there and she never once came out
she's she just decided that hey he's my
husband we're going to stay together no
no it's not that he cheated on you once
I get that it's that he's a rapist
you're a strong woman and you stand by a
rapist did you know that comment below
did you know that Bill Clinton was a
rapist
I was gonna try to do it but I'm glad he
had that because that's better than me
doing it yeah yeah I don't know man yes
no we couldn't hear anything else okay I
think none of us were in The Situation
Room I don't want to end up accidentally
dying in a way that's physically
impossible to die with cameras turning
off that should have been on I just want
to be careful yeah is what I'm saying
and we'll uh we'll check in with
Finnegan later with the uh the CLG
that's uh coming into the uh coming into
the uh the shores oh yeah so we'll check
in with that later guys or you can just
move that to later let Finnegan that he
know that he's uh sort of sitting there
and I don't have to wait uh all right so
let's talk about Tick Tock let's set
this up for you and then we're going to
go live to the hearing that's taking
place so we'll probably head uh head on
over to C-SPAN after this yeah um
there's a big fight taking place uh over
Tick Tock in Washington
um where some people well this brings us
to I guess we have to uh trash tick tock
[Laughter]
thank you
that's brilliant I'm so grateful for
rumble I was gonna say that oh sound a
little bit racist and that's fine it is
a sound I make when I kick somebody but
still no he was saying show oh chew okay
bless you
I would say it never gets old but it
does so uh The Tick Tock CEO shochu is
currently going to be testifying in
front of a I think it's Congressional
committee it's always hard to keep track
you're not going to have big names today
so this is like you know this is like
before the big boss second blood sport
where it's not the guy who flexes his
pecs but it's a guy who kind of looks
like Mick Foley
um testifying right now before Congress
because lawmakers are calling to ban the
app of tick tock now before I get to the
clips here I want to set this up for you
uh this is going to be the first
generation of people
very likely based on the science that we
have that is going to have a lower IQ
than the previous generation now let me
explain to you why that likely is and
we'll give you the science and we make
all references publicly available tick
tock's a big part of it I don't think
that people are necessarily Dumber I
think it's that their uh working memory
right your short-term memory is not
nearly as efficient as it used to be
because you're constantly bombarded with
content it's passive consumption of
content and we know what that does with
the brain we know how it rewires the
brain when you combine that with trans
indoctrination and of course Chinese
propaganda you end up with an even
greater problem than just your aunt
Tilly sending you a picture of a prairie
dog's balls on Facebook which by the way
no one used to do physically so I have
my qualms with Facebook but Tick Tock is
worse Grandma yes oh my gosh my my
grandmother you know God bless her soul
before she passed but you know it was
part there was the Silver Lining is that
she didn't go to her forwarding office
she had a forwarding office like this is
where I go two hours a day to my
forwarding office she would forward
emails oh my gosh I would get like 16 a
day which wouldn't be a promise I should
be like why didn't you respond I'm like
because you sent it from your forwarding
office I don't have a forwarding office
I have a job
with old people and forwards knock your
grandma no so in the lead up to the
hearing uh show Chu uh released this
video defending tick tock hi everyone
it's show here I'm the CEO of tick tock
I'm here in Washington DC today and uh I
have some news and updates to share with
everyone here today I'm super excited to
announce super more than 150 million
Americans on Tick Tock that's almost
half of the US coming to tiktok to
connect to create to share to learn or
just to have some fun this includes 5
million businesses that use tick tock to
reach the customers and the majority of
these are small and medium businesses
have started talking about banning Tech
talks about business owners all 150
million of you I'll be testifying before
Congress later this week to share all
that we're doing to protect Americans
using the app and deliver on our mission
to inspire creativity and to bring joy
and by the way part of the reason we
were late is he was late today because
he was too busy taping another Coco
melon segment so he was yeah he had a
lot going on I think that's unfair and I
find that video offensive because that's
actually Gwyneth Paltrow with the China
all masks on and that's what yeah and I
have that on good authority but I do
trust them yeah there's also the candle
it smells like sewer food
but the egg doesn't pick
AIDS yes exactly once again get your
Jade egg and then manufacturing to
Regina what do you wanna do you want to
go to let me go really quick by the way
hit the like button comment on YouTube
really quickly smash the rumble button
head on over to rumble we're going to
have a lot that we are not going to be
getting into uh on YouTube and just to
be clear before we move on here this is
a perfect example of and I want to go to
what we have live if we miss something
let us know but um
they expect the United States and by
they I mean the rest of the world and I
was raised in Canada because this
happens right they expect the United
States to to foot the bill for everybody
else Ukraine hey how about you all step
in NATO how about your neighbors do it
how about hey Europe how about you do it
and why do we need to spend 100
something billion dollars or commit us
100 something billion dollars before
people want to admonish we've committed
but we haven't spent all of it okay hold
your comments they want us to foot the
bill there for the security of the world
and they want to blame the United States
for standards that we apply which they
apply far more stringently themselves to
give you an example Tick Tock is not
it's not banned in the states yet you
know where it is banned China China
China China had no idea it's not allowed
in China for different reasons because
all the trans you know infiltration that
happens there where people want you to
text them on Tick Tock slide into their
DMS so your parents don't know and they
can encourage you to transition they
believe that'll poison the minds of the
youth in China or as they called them
so they don't allow it in China but now
they want to Lobby the United States to
allow because they know the irreparable
damage that can do to young people and
by the way yep I am more of a
Libertarian but one of the few
legitimate roles of government to be
clear and this is something that you can
use when people say oh so you're a
conservative what about roads what about
the military the role of the government
certainly the one legitimate role is to
protect its citizens both from exterior
and interior threats and I would say
Chinese propaganda and some content that
they won't even allow in their country
because they've seen the studies they
know the irreparable damage yeah I would
say that that's legitimate that falls
under the legitimate purview of
government to prevent and eliminate that
threat by eliminating I mean the app
it's not show too
so before we go here uh we're gonna go
to it live and fact check it just so you
know to set this up Chu also sent out an
army of propaganda influencers these are
the medium sized business owners to
which he was referring
I spend
so many hours a day on Tech talk yeah
it's part of my everyday it's now my
full-time career it's what I do faces
aggressively I've been able to not only
have opportunities from the platform
itself but I've been able to do bigger
things like you know commercial goals
acting roles
because of tick tock and because of the
fan base that I was able to grow can I
take diet kittens look and make it
better personal income like that really
comes through brand deals most of which
happen on Tick Tock so if it were to be
banned like those brand deals would go
away and so was 60 of my Consulting
business and so I'd be left with like
just a small margin of what I'm
currently making but not be sustainable
for me and my brother to really live off
of that is the backbone of American
society clearly yeah right there he runs
a few bodegas
that Zoomer here hey when people
about the American dream being Out Of
Reach I was just thinking about this but
we've talked about how actually and I
get it that there's this crazy inflation
right now for the first time the
American dream might be out of reach for
young people housing prices have gone up
but you can also move somewhere that's
maybe not the city maybe not the most
hip area but when people talk about the
American dream going away the American
dream used to be work nine to five come
home white picket fence right you have a
house a car a family enough money to go
on vacation but let me ask you this
I am 35 years old okay
um and I was thinking about this when
you think of the American dream back in
the day what people did I don't know
anyone my age or younger who works in a
Foundry
hmm not one and I know we can talk about
trades versus higher education and
gender studies but just
anyone under the age of 30 who works in
a Foundry no nobody
you could be paid well and then you can
achieve the American dream anyone here
know any good young welders hmm no no
manufacturing that was the American
dream just to make it clear you want
what they were able to experience they
were able to reap but you want to not
work with your hands and by the way it's
not lost to me I don't work with my
hands yeah I work with my brain ish well
look at the end of that video the guy I
mean just think about the argument that
he's making he's like oh man poor me if
you actually shut down Tick Tock then my
income goes away and I'm like so let me
get this straight on the one Christmas
yeah is that all you could do fill two
birds with one stone that's fantastic so
on the one hand I can I can take your
income away which okay that's fine
that's not a bad that is a bad thing
right you don't want to take somebody's
income away on the other hand I can let
the Chinese Communist Party spy on every
American citizen the United States and
potentially harm all of us including
mostly the kids
I don't know which way to go yeah it's
also a technology that targets the brain
stem yeah we know how that works it's
called persuasion technology and that's
sort of that as as
advanced As It Gets in that and they're
only getting better yes
the reason people you're talking about
it we don't sit down we don't have an
attention span like right the reason
that some cultures are good at math is
because they can sit and work on a
problem without getting distracted right
they'll just sit there and not give up
on it but when you have five second
video five second video You're gonna
look at something and go to the next
thing I want to go to this 14 year old
daughter who's on Tick Tock like this
and I when I ask her a question while
she's on Tick Tock it it's as though I
threw ice water on her back yeah well
you should also stop doing that and
which is part of your conditioning but
it's the only way I can get her
attention and then she just lifts a
finger when I say hi but she's still on
her Tick Tock yeah I know it really is
well we'll get into some of the uh the
Neuroscience with that and Kevin you
know who's a PhD here and he'll let you
know
um
we love you Kevin Kevin he was also a
marine I don't know if you knew that
square bear he's a square bear he's
brilliant but he drove into the
meta-analyzes with these and uh yeah
it's very it is incredibly harmful and
one thing I will say before we go to the
hearing that we're pretty proud of this
is pretty rare by the way uh and we
thank you for tuning in on Rumble we
have a far greater viewership on this
show than I have total social media
reach which is very rare usually you
hope for a certain percentage of your
social media reach a good portion of you
you bookmark it right for 10 a.m Eastern
and by the way that really means 10 10
10 10 but that's your fault because you
guys start funneling in late so we say
10 a.m Eastern but there are far more
people who tune in like you used to with
TV Guide watch the show for an hour and
a half two hours if it's a live stream
like today a live fact check depending
on the stream and you move on with your
day and we make the references available
for you I know that my retention is not
nearly as I can remember who I was with
what I was wearing when I saw these
films when I was young and I'd like to
comment below if you've experienced this
um because I would pay ten dollars I'd
go into a dark theater and in order to
be polite I wouldn't have my phone on
I'd be quiet and I would watch even if I
didn't like the film I'll have films now
that I like and I go did I and I'll
watch it for 20 minutes ago I already
saw this because the second there's a
boring low the second you feel like
you're not being stimulated enough you
start scrolling through your phone and
so it's gotten to the point where I put
my phone on the charger at the other end
of the room if I'm going to watch a
documentary if I'm going to watch a film
if I'm spending time with family because
I noticed it affecting me and we really
do want you to look everything old is
New Again tune it you want to know what
we think tune into the show you want to
have the context tune into the show you
want to be able to expand upon the
information that we provide you while we
make the references available and then
move on with your day that's why I'm not
tweeting out or putting Instagram
pictures of my my food or my latest
deadlift PR because who gives a we
used to sit down and it was an
experience and we would retain
information today we're being bombarded
with it and that's why you're seeing
these incredibly damaging effects almost
similar to the effects of long-term
addiction or long-term uh brain damage
back to you dead lifting yeah well you
know I don't do it do you wear a lifting
suit or no pants wait um that's working
with you so there's a point that's
working with your hands is what I'm
trying to say no I know I know I would
watch that I could I would scroll
through that but if you're not sure you
were safe have you noticed that not
yourself that you don't remember things
now like you used to yes yeah it does
rewire your brain yeah it's just uh
because what happens is you'll you'll
I'm gonna I'll be like I'm just gonna go
to tick tock for two seconds to make
sure everything because there's a girl
on a skateboard in a bikini I want to
make sure she's safe yeah yes and then
40 minutes later
I'm Gwyneth Paltrow plows into her
that's exactly I don't know what I
expect this is always How It Ends and
she's wearing a china doll mask that's
what she calls The Prestige there it is
that's a magic trick sorry just for the
people who didn't see the movie all
right yeah don't ask her how she's
prominent so got bruises all over my
body metaphorically keep going Josh
holla even talked about the app on
Wednesday saying that we learned this
week that it actually looks like Tick
Tock has infiltrated state government
websites they are very likely collecting
your personal information this is crazy
this has got to stop and the way we stop
it is by Banning it let's go now live to
uh cocomelon stand and Mr Chu speaking
of them understand the data that we're
collecting a lot of it is speculation
you know this is something they could do
they could do but if you look at the sub
text this is something that so every
company could do I'm running out of time
let me just say that if tic-tac-toes not
to take this incident this uh sensitive
information that you don't need for a
transaction and support our
comprehensive privacy bill that would be
that would be very helpful the other
thing I wanted to ask so um really this
is this is a nest yes or no
um that Tick Tock does take talk share
user information
from
companies from parent companies from
Affiliated or she had no idea what Tick
Tock was until yeah
someone wrote those notes yeah overseas
in the past yes for interoperable
interoperability purposes now after
project taxes all protected U.S data
will be stored here with the access
controlled by a special team of you guys
it goes back to the labor campaign but
just so you know he just said back then
yes can someone like fact checkers can
you bring back when they lied and said
that they weren't doing it back then
because right now what he's telling you
is uh back then yes uh but now uh we
will say no is that a Spanish accent I
have no idea I'm not entirely sure what
it is it comes from seething rage yes
because back then they were saying no so
why should we trust them now this is the
issue and you know why nothing happens
because people like chachowski they
don't they don't care nothing happens
with the section 230. they go they go
okay what am I dealing with today
probably the greatest threat to our
national security and the greatest rival
we have had since World War II a
communist that is China and not
the people of China I'm talking about
the Communist Chinese government because
I actually have empathy for the Chinese
people and you can't be bothered to it's
like a run-on sentence I don't know if
we can rewind that but she goes and uh
overseas
you you you you are bad and you should
feel bad yeah absolutely so we have a
clip of the CEO of tick tock actually
testifying I think it's either an
opening statement in response to another
question that Tick Tock is not in fact
stealing any of your information oh
really this is way back this is today
today I'm Sorry by the Chinese
government it's a private company sixty
percent of the company is owned by
global institutional investors 20 is
owned by the founder and 20 owned by
employees around the world
body dance has five board members three
of them are American I believe now Tick
Tock itself is not available in mainland
China we're headquartered in Los Angeles
and in Singapore and we have 7 000
employees in the US today
still we have heard important concerns
about the potential for unwanted foreign
access to U.S data and suggestion
manipulation U.S ecosystems
because I want this is one of those uh
this is one of those situations where
we're saying the exact same thing only
he doesn't realize it's horrifying play
the first portion of that clip about the
ownership of tick tock is not owned or
controlled by the Chinese government
is a private company sixty percent of
the company is owned by global
institutional investors twenty percent
is owned by the founder and twenty
percent owned by employees around the
world
he is saying so think about what he's
saying you could picture that exact same
phrase being spoken through words of
Terror from Alex Jones He says 60 is
owned by uh Global institutional
investors look
sixty percent of tick tock is owned by
globalist institutional investors this
is terrifying he's saying the exact same
thing oh no that puts us at ease because
well it's not the Communist Chinese
government it's institutional globalist
investors you know how human they are by
the way yeah by the way I have no vested
interest in cheap labor slave labor
continuing no okay well that makes sense
that certainly Global institutional
investors would have America's best
interests screams child safety doesn't
it yes exactly Global institutional
investors are watching out for your kids
that's what I look for on the box Global
institutionally invested and up
ah children are safe yes hey so really
quickly I think he's kind of splitting
hairs here but I want to make sure that
I have this correctly so this is a
question for the guys out in trouble
he's talking about Tick Tock and saying
hey we're not even headquartered there
we're in Singapore and we're by heavily
Chinese population in Singapore by the
way right and Los Angeles
and I think he's kind of splitting hairs
because it's bite dance yeah is the
connection splitting Arrow straight
hairs so double check me guys and make
sure is bite dance headquartered there
is that the connection that he's trying
to kind of like no no we're outside of
China completely yeah
[Music]
thank you
jeez this is this is on Tick Tock oh boy
but by the way that's not our glitch I
don't think I think that's them yeah
again
it just looks like a pumping motion and
stop it I'm saying
that video was posted 41 days ago as you
can see it has captioned me as f
at the house Energy and Commerce
Committee on March 23rd of this year
this video was posted before this
hearing was publicly noticed I think
that's a very interesting point to raise
but more concerning is the fact that it
names this chairwoman by name
your own Community guidelines State keep
in mind these things are allowed on Tick
Tock where we've been banned and we get
fact checked and we are accused of
encouraging Violence by encouraging you
to stand up peacefully against your
government Tick Tock allows this and I
don't know it's not because of a vested
interest let's keep watching extremist
organizations individuals or Acts when
there is a threat to Public Safety or an
account is used
to glorify off-platform violence we ban
the account this video has been up for
41 days it is a direct threat to the
chairwoman of this committee the people
in this room and yet it Still Remains on
the platform and you expect us to
believe that you are capable of
maintaining the data security privacy
and security of 150 million Americans
where you can't even protect the people
in this room
I think that is a blatant display of how
vulnerable people who use tick tock are
you couldn't take actions 21 days when a
clear threat a very violent threat to
the chairwoman of this committee and the
members of this committee was posted on
your platformac
you damn well know she doesn't have to
look at her notes notice that check the
data and security of this committee or
the 150 million users of your app
because it is an extension of the CCP
and with that I yield back amen snapper
no we're going to move on
General lady yields back if I would like
a moment to lie California I wish they
would have let him kind of just kind of
hang himself just a little bit yeah a
little bit this is the one problem too
with politicians they're more interested
in grandstanding than actually sort of
getting to the bottom of it because and
this is also the problem with these not
always necessarily being uh the exact
same threat uh I don't know with this
committee if it's considered perjury I
believe it is but it's happened in the
past like fauci you know like I think it
was about 117 times and they get away
with it anyway no one ever actually gets
exactly charged right never no one ever
actually has to deal with consequences
but Hootie they brought it in because
just now we had that clip keep in mind
he said we used to but we won't going
forward with our new I think he said
Texas Project something like that I
can't be we're still waiting on the clip
but we do have an update from uh
gingersnap that Beijing take state board
seat in uh bite dances key China
entities that's what it is okay so
essentially yes and his uh bite dance is
the parent company okay so they're
trying they're basically trying to say
oh no Tick Tock it's a subsidiary of
bite dance bite dance is the parent
company that's where the game is played
don't let them tell you Los Angeles and
Singapore and has nothing to do with it
because it's like okay like we're wholly
owned by a a caliphate right it's like
yeah we have no ties to it you just own
us a caliphate that's run by thousands
of tiny Fists of Fury that's true
dishonest but guys bring us that Source
it shouldn't be very hard to find of
course that they lied in the past they
have constantly been saying that no no
we it's not spyware no no we don't share
your information now he just admitted
well we did but we won't moving forward
when are there consequences for the fact
that you were doing it then and you were
lying
this is why Americans so why don't you
trust your institutions well take a
guess what are they doing it should be
oh so back then you lied back then your
company lied great we're gonna slap you
with a fine and someone's going to be
making a perp walk instead it's ah you
rap scallion okay we're gonna keep an
eye on you did they get that to us so
what we have here is leaked audio from
80 internal Tick Tock meeting shows that
U.S user data has been repeatedly
accessed from China wow um this is from
a external auditor who stated I feel
like these tools uh with these tools
there's some backdoor access user data
in almost all of them yeah from June of
20. well we knew that but I want them
denying it they issued a statement
denying that they were uh for a long
time denying that they were spying on
Americans that's the issue is the
constant lying and uh let's listen to
him more right now Mr shochu is speaking
let us know what the hashtag is right
now as this goes on The Tick Tock
hashtag because we'll be live fact
checking it okay alarming information
brought to light by whistleblowers have
shown that social media companies are
intimately aware of your brother against
sister their products on young women
despite this they withheld those
things it shows a pattern notice that
Democrats have the notes and the
Republicans are pissed extreme not
saying Republicans a solution to your
problems but Democrats I'm sure the
cause of a lot of them and I think Dan
bongino reiterates that pretty damn well
who's also on Rumble Fusion models on
mental health or safety and if so how
and when are those findings made public
and if not do you believe they are
necessary
congresswoman we rely on external third
parties and fund their research to help
us understand some of these issues for
example we worked with the digital
Wellness Lab at the Boston Children's
Hospital to understand the 60-minute
time limit that we put for all our under
18 users and we are supportive of
legislation that provides more funding
for research like for example for the
NIH yeah because I know they're funding
yeah and I know that after you know 60
Minutes is about my limit of watching
Buffalo Bill
hey I think more research I think we do
have that clip who do we have that clip
we got the clip which clip of him lying
issuing a statement or whatever I'm
saying yeah so a clip is actually the
Chief Operating Officer lying and yeah
okay let's let's dig into a few things
if we could specifically about tick
tock's links to the Chinese Communist
party in responsible my colleagues Tick
Tock claimed earlier this year that the
company has never shared data never with
the Chinese government is that correct
that is correct yes and has never shared
data with the Chinese Communist party is
that correct
we will never share data period uh my
question was in the past tense have has
Tick Tock ever shared data with the
Chinese Communists listen we have never
shared data with the Chinese government
correct but the Chinese Communist party
yes correct uh do you have look at the
arrogance yes correct and you just heard
them right now too we used to you just
heard him right now say we did
[Music]
thank you
see that is that what he actually said
we used to in the past was he referring
to the fact that they used to give that
data to the he said they used to no he
said they used to use personal data they
used to my personal data amazing and you
can guess what they were doing with that
data considering that uh of course they
are is it possible that the uh woman I
don't see color but she didn't look like
she was Chinese right
um was keep in mind your monitor is that
photo negative it's in dark mode so
you're seeing a photo negative thank God
she's actually Ugandan but go on I I was
gonna say it I hope the same goes for me
I want people to judge me on the content
of my words and character not my not my
face which looks pretty good in this
life
compared to Alex Jones I don't want to
make this about myself because this is
about uh I mean about uh
isn't that terrifying there's never any
any accountability it's amazing
this is the same kind of thing they've
done here right so the CEO and the CEO
can get up and say tick tock is never
shared data
bike dance maybe right but not us right
and next you're going to tell me that
you know
Corona came from a lab right right
obviously if you can eat an undercooked
bat Yes somewhere in China then you
deserve what you get is what I'm trying
to say no whenever I go to Five bats I
get my medium well
always gotta be careful medium well is
good I can make sure medium well all the
way that's right and make sure you know
what cave it's coming from if the bat
smells cavey you know you got a problem
yeah exactly right we call them cave
apples in China it's deter it's
basically synonymous with gamey this fat
smells gamey like you just say Katie
it's better descriptor but by the way
let's contrast this this is why we're so
excited about Rumble uh while we're
talking about what's happening and them
sharing information right Chinese
spyware effectively Rumble told the
government of France to go screw
themselves right they disabled access in
France because the French government
demanded that Rumble remove content from
what they claimed were Russian news
sources and Rumble responded by saying
Rumble is growing so rapidly because we
trust adults to make decisions for
themselves about what ideas they can
express so Rumble said to an entire
entire government and I know what you're
thinking is France really considered a
government that matters anymore no but
the principle remains they said all
right
you want us to Bent
a ban
because keep in mind in in in YouTube
land it's you're not even allowed to
have non-pro Ukraine not and to Ukraine
right non-pro Ukraine content yeah
that's part of their guidelines non-pro
Ukraine content France didn't say get
rid of just Russian propaganda they said
get rid of Russian news sources and
Rumble said well then I guess you're
just going to have to disable the entire
website and that's why we have an entire
month free of mug Club Lottery
crowder.com mug club right we've
partnered up with Rumble we could not be
happier here I tell you this in full
they have never once not once tried to
censor what I say or ask me to change
what I say how I say it they've never
once had any input as to who was in this
show every time we go to them and say
look we might do this might be a risk
they said well that's fine look it's
your it's your channel you do whatever
you want to do yeah
and that's the thing and they're
Canadian
but Brian I want to go back to something
you said at the end of that quote We
Trust adults to make decisions for
themselves about ideas they can express
and you said Bravo yes
sorry guys let's speak French think
about that yeah that is such a basic
like the sky is blue and I breathe
oxygen statement and we're like oh thank
God I know our reaction now to something
so basic and fundamental is at least
somebody's standing up but that's what I
worry about that's what I mean so you
can get very used to insanity and you
can get and and these kinds of things
it's like the Frog and water when you
raise the temperature slowly that we
have to be careful that the water isn't
boiling you know by the way this wasn't
Illuminati just so people don't I was
saying
put it in the vagina in a little
quadrant down there so people know that
we're live streaming I want you to
continue your point sorry but I did this
and everyone's going to think that I'm
sleeping with Rihanna
oh God she's she's got yeah that's uh
yeah she has a horrible stutter though
so she's an inspiration does she really
Ella Ella Ella hey I thought my radio
was broken ah
I'm a child Brian no your point was
correct though we do get used to
overcoming obstacles like stutters yes
what yeah well like Joe Biden remember
all of a sudden he developed a stutter
when he was running for president I
heard he's got at the age of seven but
by the way he might just be a uh what's
the animatronic puppet and he's
glitching yeah because he I think he
died in 2017. yeah that's the rumor I
don't want to spread nope you know what
I mean yeah they change the tint on the
Tupac hologram and just put on a little
hair piece that's exactly that's exactly
right so let's go back to what they're
saying here now here's okay let's see
Republican in Florida I'm willing to bet
he's not using notes as much we we do
take these issues very seriously yes or
no and we do provide resources for
anyone who types in anything that sir
yes or no
you're not willing to answer the
question
or take any responsibility I think this
was regarding content incredible suicide
the technology and the harms it creates
it's just very very sad very sad it's
very sad this is why Congress needs to
enact a comprehensive privacy and data
security law to give Americans more
control over their information and to
protect our children we must save our
children from Big tech companies like
yours who continue to abuse and
manipulate them for your own game doing
good I just have a hard time taking this
guy seriously yeah because he looks like
uh he looks like it looks Mr Peabody
yeah
it sounds a little drunk he looks like
melting Bob Barr
it's so true to be like uh hey I don't
know the answer like it's a simple yes
or no
no it's like I don't know how to take it
I'll take that is a maybe
I said no
well I don't
be good did he say
S I don't know what sound anymore like
Louie Anderson yeah my dad used to bang
me on the bar at the buffet and this is
why I'm damaged
[Applause]
oh let's go to miss pearl necklace
operations that that serve up harmful
content and has a corrosive effect on
our kids mental and physical well-being
for many years I've sounded the alarm in
this Committee of how big Tech platforms
like Tick Tock and Facebook and
Instagram Facebook she got that in there
surveil track gather personal private
information and use it along with data
Brokers to Target and influence our
Behavior this is a much broader issue
than Tick Tock in China there are other
malign actors across the world she's
going to go into Russian and election
isn't she to use it as an element of
social control uh and influence peddling
uh and worse let's see and as I detailed
in this committee last year when we
passed the on our online Privacy Law the
harms to children are very serious and
demand Swift action big Tech platforms
profit immensely from keeping children
addicted they do not care about the
Privacy safety and health of our kids
correct they are the modern day tobacco
and cigarette companies that for so long
resisted and misled Congress and it took
okay so this is the problem here this is
more grandstanding where she wants to
but it's the opposite of Comedy so I've
told you about this when I was on Fox
news for four and a half years they
would get mad at me because coming from
a comedy background you know brevity is
a soul of wit and so I'd sit there and
be like an Alan Colmes type and by the
way he was a nice guy I like him but
they would bring me on with leftist and
they would say well I don't know where
Steven Gutt is a college degree but you
know I studied political science and I
would answer it never graduated grade
school what's your point
and I got called into the second floor
and said you're not taking enough time
the goal on television is to like take
one point and drag it out for as much
time as you can that's how you beat the
other person I'm like I would rather
make a point effectively yeah the next
point right the problem is right okay
how does it harm children now here's
what's really important here when you're
hearing Democrats and Republicans
question there are two different views
uh for the future the internet okay
they're saying children aren't safe so
are you talking about targeting children
right in in in promoting hormone
replacement therapy are you talking
about sex changes with children no no
you can't do that because the assistant
uh Health secretary Rachel Levine said
that that's going to be normal in the
United States the wheels will move on so
let's look at this when we're talking
about protecting children both sides are
right both sides are talking about
protecting a free internet I think
there's a problem with spying on
Americans right I think that's a problem
but Americans should be able to choose
what they watch one world the world that
Rumble sees the world that we see the
world that conservatives see okay let me
start with the left world so I'm gonna
so my left your right I guess this stuff
so just assume this is left you're
watching the screen
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what you see so we both agree on privacy
issues but we don't agree on allowing
children to only select age-appropriate
content but furthermore more importantly
adults to be able to make their own
decisions regarding content so when
people say the far left and the far
right man we really only agree on one
thing and that's why they're
grandstanding and not getting down to
Brass tax because there is a Chasm
between us I want to be Crystal Clear
while we're talking not just about Tick
Tock the vision is you get to choose
what it is that you watch and that is
what you see that is not what is
happening on Facebook on YouTube I don't
know if you know this I can't find
anything I search for on YouTube anymore
it's not possible that's how YouTube
started there is no YouTube anymore
that's why we're starting this Exodus to
rumble and hopefully there will be other
Alternatives as well Rumble would like
to see Alternatives and competitors
they're a media platform they're not a
social media platform now let me kind of
get down to them you guys can let me
know what's happening live because it is
important to provide this context here
okay there is destruction of the brain
happening
with passive consumption of content and
that's not hyperbole you can check the
references we'll make them all publicly
available but I'll give you a snapshot
here so things like YouTube Shorts
Facebook shorts Instagram reels right uh
uh and Tick Tock of course was sort of
the Catalyst for all of this now think
of this for a second these are the most
powerful companies in the world they all
have access to the data and the science
and they know oh hold on a second five
second views are not good we shouldn't
be encouraging people to do that but you
have Tick Tock then Instagram follows
then Facebook follows and YouTube
follows not one of them said wait a
second we know this is bad maybe we
should stop but take our word for it now
when we tell you that we are telling the
truth here's what's happening and here's
I believe this is a doctor this next
clip or a neuroscientist some kind of an
expert because I never graduated grade
school talking about what happens to
your brain with these five second
dopamine releases Non-Stop Dr Ziegler
let's break it down what is Tick Tock
brain
is something that we know has been going
on for you for years but finally we have
the research to support it and what that
means is that the brains particularly
the developing brain of young children
and teens is starting to get quite used
to these short form videos to the point
where what the actual brain science
behind it is is that we see dopamine
which is your feel-good hormone it is
what is involved in addiction it's
what's involved in the reward circuitry
of your brain we see that it gets spiked
up so when they're looking through and
they're scrolling through these real
quick videos that's what's happening
they're getting these dopamine hits that
feel good just the way it does when
people sometimes use drugs or they use
alcohol or they become addicted to other
things and so that's now kind of the
frightening data to support what we've
wondered all along which is yes in fact
there is an actual neurological reason
why looking at those kinds of videos is
just so addicting yeah it's also gross
but let me give you a few uh quick uh
pointers I think you need to know we
talked about this a long time ago with
pornography I think it was Gary Wilson
there's your brain on porn if you go to
Club you'll be able to find it by the
way it helped a lot of men break their
pornography addiction and by the way
that is a thing I'm not just talking
about the Sears catalog I'm not talking
about nudie magazines but a tab and a
tab and a tab and a tab and a tab a tab
of porn is incredibly addictive arguably
more addictive than many drugs but
here's the research on this mobile phone
addiction short-term memory function
this is you can go find this on
researchgate or our website they were
found to significantly and negatively
correlate with each other a pediatrician
John Hutton and he's a director of the
Cincinnati Children's Hospital said it's
like an infinite candy store Tick Tock
in particular is a dopamine machine if
you want kids to pay attention they need
to practice paying attention here's one
more clip from a psychologist Jonathan
height Jonathan height talking about it
and then I'll give you a startling
statistic regarding IQ when human beings
are raised without much Independence but
yes with a phone and they spend their
childhood just interacting with the
screen and especially social media
I believe it it messes up cortical
development
the girls in particular the rates of
anxiety and depression are more the much
more than 100 since 2010 the rate of
self-harm hospitalizations for self-harm
is nearly tripled
for pre-teen girls
so gen Z is in big big trouble
they're hurting they're fragile they're
not doing well in the workplace managers
are finding them very hard to work with
so we have a generation that's running
off the rails well women being hard to
work with that's not necessarily new I
know what you're saying but he's talking
about it in a different facet here's the
thing IQ
is down for the first time in 100 years
that's crazy this comes from Daily Mail
queue I think you can bring up the
biggest decrease was in people aged 18
to 22 and those less well educated and
here's the thing the left says well on a
second shout your period shout your
gender right the world needs to see this
because we need to stop what
working depression is up suicide is up
mental illness is up people with
feelings of hopelessness are up they
view their potential prospects more
negatively than the generation before
them so this idea that everything needs
to be shared at all times
it's not helping no it's not working
it's it is having deleterious effects
it's also worse because that study was
conducted and finished prior to the
pandemic just before the pandemic so
imagine things were terrible it was a
dumpster fire to begin with and then the
pandemic comes in and you have teachers
protesting right and kids are and kids
are isolated in their rooms it's worse
for their own safety and having to wear
masks for two years like my kids were in
California this is almost like the law
generation essentially for the United
States because of policies that we've
allowed to happen because of things that
we've had happen with covet and the
scare tactics of the left and the media
and doctors saying you can't go and be
around anybody it's affected our kids in
a way that we will not fully understand
for years to come which is why I'm a
conservative and out of the closet man
you think I'm kidding that's exactly
what it is the gender insanity and and
watching my daughter sit there in a mask
and be separated from her friends that
long I was like oh I forgot I'm a
conservative but here's the beauty of it
so here's one thing they're not
complaining about right as a matter of
fact they we have to have the YouTube
dump button because our rebuttal yeah
the kind of content you're about to see
is what they have a problem with so in
the left zootopia and by the way they
had it for a year or two your child is
at home with a mask scroll scroll scroll
scroll scroll now they sort of faint
outrage at privacy saying oh I need to
protect privacy but they wanted your
children they instituted they instituted
they mandated through policy your
children are home in a mask isolated
from their friends isolated from other
family members from small groups from
church activities or going to buy some
petunia seeds whatever the hell it was
in Michigan so they're isolated but the
good news is they could all stay at home
and scroll through the kind of content
that the left demands be left on the
platform and
I want to talk to the kids hey kids oh
hi kids hey kids
your parents screwed up
it's okay to say so of course that's why
I made a patreon so that we could talk
about it so that we could connect in a
way that has more privacy
think about this for a second your kids
are isolated from everyone who could
have a positive influence typically
speaking of someone like that wanted to
reach your children privately they'd at
least have to spring for a van
I was going to say and I'm going to say
this that that worries me that guy
because when I watch him or her I'm
sorry I think it's a her it I I just I
end up and I'm an adult I want to cut my
huge dick off yeah I know right so can
you imagine what it's like for a kid
yeah and that's that guy's downright
hypnotic if you just wear sunglasses
well he ends every video too by saying
everything floats down here it's
which is really weird to me floats uh by
the way there's no goop no hit the
rumble button Smash It and if you're
watching on YouTube please head over to
rumble it's for today it's going to be
free right all the mug Club is free and
we'll be able to get into more than we
can right here because YouTube well they
want to act as though they're protecting
your privacy they want to act as though
they want you to have a safe internet
guess what they ban what we say and they
still keep the shorts up there and they
still thrust the gender bending Carnival
top into your timeline regardless don't
be fooled by charlatans and act like we
can find common ground there's no common
ground with these people I have a
question yeah has anybody asked uh Mr
Chu
um if why it was banned in China why why
is Tick Tock this platform you are
advocating for because it's it's fun
it's good for business and all that
other stuff why is it that it was banned
in your country sir has anybody asked
him that direct question I'd like but
you know what else though too it's not
just banned in the country of China but
it is banned in a lot of countries on
government devices yeah so not your
device but government devices which
would suggest what maybe some national
security issue you know where government
devices correct even the United States
government devices can't have Tick Tock
even in the European Union even in
Canada and that's a really messed up
Place India Taiwan taiwan's an obvious
one or as China says I don't know why
never here Taiwan Pakistan even
Afghanistan they got one thing right
yeah the people who are forcefully
circumcising women
is too far that's a no is that in
Afghanistan that's no that's no I guess
it's a little more Russian because you
know sort of Eastern they circumcised
women in Somalia get it straight that's
well they do it in Afghanistan too yeah
do they oh yeah there's a it's a
different thing though it's more of a
ritual I've not heard that I think I
have an answer for you though at least a
a scenario right I talked to you about
Tick Tock and bite dance I think they
actually have a version of tick tock
that is available in China except it has
like it's educational it's educational
yeah she trains their kids to do things
but I think it's also that degree of
separation right so we actually have a
clip real quick if you want to play it
right now uh the CEO um I kind of I
guess won't really answer and see if he
was or say if he was prepped by bite
dance for his is this today this is
today from just a little bit earlier I
believe so we can bring that up and play
it if you want yeah let's bring that up
and play it and then let's continue to
live fact check this but here's the
thing the main takeaway here today
is yeah they screwed up in the past and
when they were asked about it before
they they did they lied about it and
they said that they weren't spying on
you and they said that your information
was Secure but today they really mean it
though really mean yeah that's what
you're that's what you should leave this
with or China is the enemy of a free
people the communist government of China
that shouldn't be controversial to say
the Communist Chinese government is the
enemy of a free people and anything that
comes from there certainly media wise
needs to be questioned needs to be seen
through an incredibly critical lens
that's what I would say the takeaways
but let's watch this video here from
earlier today with Mr the device but I
prepared for this hearing my team here
in DC can you guarantee that no one that
bites based on a role in preparing you
for today's hearing like I said
Congressman this is a high profile
hearing a lot of people around the world
were sending me wishes and unsolicited
advice but I prepared for this hearing
my team here in DC
ah it should be interesting no yeah they
didn't yeah I have a question were there
any uyghurs on that team my we get rid
of Han if I had an eight ball would say
all signs pointed nah okay because I
like diversity but here's something that
people need to understand though yeah
and of course uyghurs shouldn't be put
you know in a in a prison uyghur
shouldn't be arrested but here's the
thing that China does uh understand and
you need to understand the motive there
which Americans are blind to they are
saying hold on a second Islam is not
just a religion it's a political
prescription and it is not compatible
with a horrible political prescription
right the Communist Chinese government
when Ben Carson said hold on as I would
say that the uh Quran and Sharia law is
not compatible with the Constitution and
American law people said how dare you
say that that's racist they understand
that in order to preserve a culture
wrongfully by the way because it's a
communist culture it's a terrible
culture but they understand that a
religion that comes in and tells people
how to subvert culture through a system
of laws is a threat now they're awful
about it these violations of human
rights that's why you have people in the
NBA who turn a blind eye to it it's this
unb it's this Web of Lies that they
cannot possibly untangle because they
say Islam's uh Islam is just a religion
like any other no it's not Christianity
is not a political system and then they
say in the Chinese government is great
because they sell our Jersey to Ohana
second they're also now oppressing
Muslims who you said we're not a problem
and you also attacked Ben Carson and
conservatives for saying that Sharia law
is not compatible with the Constitution
so which is it I don't know more money
please more money please money yeah and
you would allow people at a game in the
United States of America to hold up a
sign that says I love LeBron but you
wouldn't allow them to held up a sign
that says through the uyghurs or China
is bad or anything like that he actually
removed their ability for free speech
there in the United States hey how
popular is the NBA on Tick Tock I bet
you they have a profile right can
someone bring that up for us the players
and the organization that'd be
interesting let's go back to Chu
speaking does not allow illegal drugs
just do it just do in it do it did in
China I believe they don't allow this
but I will need to check I don't run
their business
and my guess and and it would would do
and allow for 41 days a threat against
uh doing that's the app in China that is
like Tick Tock yes that is being used
there so he's asking about it can I
speak photo in and I'm sorry I didn't
hear the second part of what you said
well we had a threat against the
chairman of our committee that was on
your side for 41 days my guess is that
would not be allowed in China that
content is is violative I'll look into
the specifics
if it violates our guidelines you'll be
taken down on Tick Tock yeah surely it
appears that it does but the problem is
that that I'm what I'm trying to get at
is you seem to be able to prevent
this content in China
but you so not even taking it down just
prevent it from being posted and yet it
it's it's all it's on your website so I
have a couple of questions about uh you
you said earlier as soon as you find the
first information so how quickly does
your algorithm detect keywords or
content that involve illicit drug
trafficking before these posts are
self-reported or used by others we have
about 40 000 people working on this now
together with the machines that we train
I don't think any company in our
industry can be perfect at this this is
a real big challenge for industry but
our goal is to get this any violative
content including illegal drugs down to
a very very small number that's the
problem when we have these hearings
and of your your colleagues and
competitors and we always hear apologies
and we always hear we want to do better
at this but it it just doesn't seem to
keep improving and we see her hearing
stories of our of our children and and
obviously that's been talking about it's
a dog in this fight by the way because
Whoville has been ravaged by fentanyl
you later drugs or other Controlled
Substances
Congressman we do publish that in a
transparency report I can get my team to
get the information to yours thank you I
appreciate that also any follow-ups
here's the problem with all this I think
Americans have to take responsibility
for a technology that has already been
adapted as you were talking about by
Facebook and all these American
companies right so the cat's out of the
back Jews out of the bottles so I do
think that laying this all at China's
doorstep I know it's spyware but I think
we as Americans and parents have to take
responsibility no you're right you're
saying hey man it's a it's damaging
technology yes it's distracting it's bad
for you in every way maybe as bad as any
drug you can think of yeah you know so
so if we are creating a generation of
addicts whose IQ for the first time in a
hundred years I call that Defcon five
yeah no which means you know and if you
can lay and if these experts like
Jonathan height and this other woman are
laying it at the that The Tick Tock
Etc alter then this is a national
security threat yes and here's the thing
is yes you're right American companies
need to be held account
but they're also Following the Leader
right China's leading the dance Tick
Tock was the first one to do shorter and
shorter and shorter and so when America
that's a problem when you have the
Communist Chinese government and a
company right that has a vested interest
and of course forwarding the ideas the
um I guess I should say the world view
of China sorry what I meant to say is
globalist uh Institutional Investor yeah
because that's not that's not a problem
at all when Americans say let's follow
your lead American companies right we
used to spearhead we used to innovate
and instead they're saying well on a
second China is a huge market so we need
to make sure that we're doing what it is
that Tick Tock is doing yes parents need
to be respected that's the genius of
China yeah they make you dependent
that's exactly what they're doing in
Africa that's what they're doing all
over the world they they come in and go
we'll build your roads man we'll build
your entire infrastructure we are your
friend right and then you become a you
you become Reliant on it and that's
exactly what's happened with the
American economy and you if you're if
you're John Cena I'm telling you right
now the reason he had to apologize in
Chinese was because they came to him and
said hey dude talk to Richard Gere if
you have any questions about where your
career is about to go right he he made
one speech at the Oscars about Tibet and
he never worked in a big film again yeah
that's exactly what happened to John
Cena think oh we can't make money bro
unless you can sell this stuff to China
you're out of a job yeah especially so
it sucks as bad as you know the Fast and
Furious series
um
that's where I dropped that's the rock
yeah no no no I know but I thought John
Cena was in that John Cena's in it is
his dumb's brother oh really yeah you
know what no no you're right you're
right hold on we're both right I
couldn't see him
for me I'm sorry I didn't see the movies
I read the books
um
good good books too I know yeah yeah
it's always awful to read the
descriptors of Ronda Rousey's stand-in
work I can't imagine a book of like and
then she said uh you want some of this
and uh she smelled really bad but you
know just go watch the movie she tried
an arm bar and it didn't work uh is
there anything else that they are
bringing us in that we've missed or
otherwise we can watch a little more
should we go to rumble I guess we've
been I didn't realize how long we've
been here let's go to rumble we've done
so guys we are going to continue uh
streaming this right now mug Club is
free all month on Rumble uh and fact
check this live we're also going to have
there's no way we could do this on
YouTube never our agent gay William who
is Cuban he is gay he is to the right of
Attila the Hun and uh don't get him
started on Puerto Ricans which means
that we will and Brian Callan has been
here Brian count I guess you're not on
the road this week but it's Portland
Portland April April 20th 21 22. okay
and Magooby's Joke House by the way
that'll be uh I think sometime at the
end of April either way because I don't
like the name of gooby's joke house it's
right on there uh right on par with uh
Regina Saskatchewan it's a little
depressing hit the like button smash the
rumble button and if you are not already
subscribed you don't need to pay
anything tomorrow we are doing a show
Friday uh where we will all be here 10
a.m Eastern but you gotta go to a lot of
credit.com right now head on over to
rumble gay William can't do it here
foreign